i literally just
played you know the movie interstellar
hadn't come out and i go it's not a big
part but i am a guy alone on a planet
you know and i don't know if i should
follow it up with the guy who's alone on
a planet
nobody
[Music]
goodwill hunting that movie is so much
of my 20s and ben affleck's 20s like we
wrote that together and just the whole
story of getting it made was one whole
thing but then once we got it made to
have robin sign up to do it was really
that's really what got us a green light
and and i just have so many memories of
that guy he changed our lives and he and
he couldn't have been more gracious more
hard working as writers like he was a
guy who could come in and just throw
lines out for instance the last line of
that movie he reads a letter from me and
he says son of a [ __ ] he stole my line
that wasn't scripted robin just did that
we had scripted that he just kind of
sits there and takes it in and realizes
that my character is gone and he didn't
say anything he just kind of took that
moment and the one that's in the movie
he just said son of a [ __ ] he stole my
line and i was with gus van sant the
director we were both next to the camera
and i remember grabbing him like this
like shaking him like because we knew
that was it the second he said it and
then we probably did 10 more takes after
that because robin would just go until
he literally had mined everything in
that beautiful brain of his yeah he just
was a really special guy
sean
if the professor calls about that job
just tell him sorry
i had to go see about a girl
well
some [ __ ]
stole my life
[Music]
we wrote that movie specifically ben and
i wrote it because we wanted the parts
as actors
and at the time there was a really
popular movie that we all loved called
reservoir dogs quentin tarantino's first
movie
and the story we had heard was that
because harvey keitel signed up for the
movie quentin got i think it was half a
million dollars that was his budget and
he could make the movie and so we wrote
that part that robin eventually took we
called it the harvey keitel part looking
for an actor who could get us money
because ben and i wanted to star in the
movie and we knew we were worth nothing
so we needed to get somebody and we
wrote it really open-ended you know we
wrote it okay they're from the same
neighborhood so they kind of understand
each other but we also knew we could
adjust it if morgan freeman or somebody
like denzel washington wanted to come in
and play it we could make that character
from roxbury and like kind of explore
the kind of historic racial tension in
boston if meryl streep took the part we
could instead of a father-son
relationship it would be a mother-son
relationship so we really left it open
because we wanted to cast as wide a net
as possible because we just
we're trying to get the movie made we
went from literally
the year before
billy crystal was hosting the oscars and
we were shooting goodwill hunting in
toronto and we were watching it on tv at
our little condo so the whole cast was
betting on who they thought would win
and gus van sant the director was with
us and we just kind of you know on our
couch watching the oscars
and from that we went to the very next
year sitting in the front row and billy
crystal
in the in the medley that he would the
musical number that he would open the
show with actually started to sing about
ben and me and it was just
completely surreal it took years to kind
of
process what happened that night it was
utterly surreal
[Music]
saving private ryan
spielberg put everyone in boot camp but
he made you feel like separate right it
was one better than that he didn't make
me go to boot camp separately he made me
not go to boot camp so that the other
guys would resent me
so
they all went through this kind of
experience and they all bonded but
because i was the character they were
looking for and they resented this guy
that they were risking their lives to go
find steven purposely kept me away from
them and let them know that i hadn't
been made to go to boot camp they're a
very tight kind of cohesive unit i'm an
outsider who they they resent
it doesn't make any sense
it doesn't make any sense sir why why
why do i deserve to go
why not any of these guys they all
fought just as hard as me
is that what they're supposed to tell
your mother
when they send her another folded
american flag
tell her that when you found me
i was here and i was with the only
brothers that i have left
and there's no way i was gonna desert
them
i got that part going back to robin
williams when we were in boston we were
rehearsing for good will hunting
and
spielberg came in because he was
shooting amistad and he was shooting a
scene with anthony hopkins at the
capitol and it was you know across
boston commons from where we were
rehearsing and robin took ben and me
to
meet steven because he knew it was
never a bad thing to meet like you know
the greatest filmmaker of all time and
and how much we'd appreciate that and i
had put myself on tape and i had read
for private ryan and i hadn't been cast
he met me in person and he said i think
i know you from somewhere and i said
well i did this movie called courage
under fire and he goes that's the one he
goes you know that's funny i said to my
wife that's the exact type of person i'd
want to play private ryan but he's too
he's too thin because i'd lost 40 pounds
to because i was playing a heroin addict
and courage under fire and so it was
only because robin introduced me to him
that he went oh okay no you're you're
you're you're you're the kind of guy i'm
looking for for that job so robin not
only got our dream and good will hunting
made he actually got me the role in
saving private ryan as well in a way
the talented mr ripley
patricia highsmith wrote a character
that's very different than the one that
in anthony's version of the talented mr
ripley her take on it was when you read
those books you're enjoying the fact
that he's killing these people and these
people are very kind of two-dimensional
and anthony thought it was a lot more
interesting if you made it about these
people who were three-dimensional rather
than kind of hating them and and being a
total sociopath was somebody who just
wanted to belong and had his nose
pressed up against the glass and it was
a completely different take than i
expected even going into it anthony just
had a great love for all of his
characters and i think that comes across
in the movie i haven't seen that movie
in a long time but it seems to be the
one of the ones that lasted
dickie greenleaf
who's that
it's tom
tom ripley
tom ripley
we were at princeton together
okay
did we know each other
hello uh well i knew you so i suppose
you must have known me and we shot that
movie for 37 million dollars which was
not a lot of money
for that movie john seal was the
cinematographer it required every
department just really really pushing to
kind of the limit of what could be done
for it to look that good and for us to
shoot it that fast and we it was six day
weeks every week i remember sundays was
just we'd all just sleep so we'd just be
ready for monday morning because it was
a marathon i was tasked with like trying
to look like jude law which meant that
every day i came home from work and i
got on a treadmill when i ran six miles
they rented me this beautiful palazzo i
needed a treadmill and the only
treadmill at the time in in rome was at
the at the hilton and so i moved kind of
out of town up on the hill to the hilton
cavalieri which was kind of lonely which
was good for the part but you know
you're in rome who wants to who wants to
live at the hilton right who are you to
say anything to me so who are you to
tell me anything actually i really
really do not want to be on this boat
with you
i can't move without you moving
gives me the creeps you give me the
creeps you can't shut it out
that's a prosthetic gag because what
anthony wanted was was the hit in a
quick exchange of dialogue and then for
the blood to start and so
i remember jude getting up at like two
or three in the morning to go before
everybody with the makeup team and they
built this thing on his face that was
very fragile so i'm sure we would have
shot
probably the bulk of the scene the day
before you know because it's a pretty
intense scene on the boat between the
two of us when you do something like
that you're walking around with wires
attached to you and like it's like
nobody touch him you know and it's like
everything is get you down to the boat
get him where he needs to be you know
and then everybody get ready be in
position and you know three two one boom
and then the thing opens and then you
have to take it all off and then you
just put blood on him and then we carry
on with the scene and so we would have
shot that over a couple days
the ocean's trilogy
yeah the trick to those movies is it's
supposed to look kind of tossed off and
nonchalant and all of that but it's very
highly choreographed the cast because we
were all used to
kind of headlining movies and carrying
them and all that responsibility and
pressure and you work you're in every
shot every day and suddenly you know
you're working two or three or four days
a week which is unheard of stephen had
the real heavy lifting stephen's job was
to do you know try to keep 11 story
lines going try to keep the you know the
the right rhythm and pace to it you know
they have to be fun you know but the
heist has to like that gag has that all
has to kind of work and so i remember
riding up
in the elevator with him one night we
were in las vegas and i said are you
gonna play any any blackjack while
you're here he goes i have one big bet
it's like a hundred million dollar bet
and and i don't have time for anything
else like this the only thing i'm i'm
focused on
oh let the sun beat down upon my face
stars to fill my dreams
i am a traveler in both time and space
to be where i have been
i don't even understand what happened in
there what did i say
you called his niece a [ __ ] very cheap
one what she's seven you're currently
confined to bed with a wicked case
i'm sorry
okay
so what does this mean
it means you stay here well we rarely
kept a straight face i mean what's in
the movie are the takes where we didn't
kind of fall out laughing because we
were pretty unprofessional steven used
to complain he was like the teacher
trying to keep everybody in line but but
we just had so much fun together and it
was such a good
group there was no ego on those sets if
you were the last person to get to set
you know because you get you all get
called at the same time and the last
person invariably got a round of
applause like standing ovation from
everyone else even if you're like two
minutes early to set like if you're the
last one so kind of the opposite of what
you might expect in a situation where
ego could get involved it just never
happened
[Music]
the bourne franchise
when i signed up for the first one i
signed up for one it's like well if the
first one works you have to do two more
i don't think anybody thought it would
work so they were like no one's fine we
went over schedule on that movie and
that's always a bad kind of indicator
usually it means the film's in trouble
you know 9 11 happened like while we
were in post-production and so the movie
ended up coming out i think a year after
it was supposed to come out none of us
were anticipating it being a
in fact it opened against two big movies
scooby-doo which sounds you know silly
in retrospect but those movies are you
know they they find a very big audience
and wind talkers there was a nick cage
movie that was coming out that was a big
budget movie bigger much bigger than us
and all three of those movies were
opening on the same friday we were just
hoping that you know we could kind of
make a little dent i still remember
because the scooby-doo made 54 million
dollars that weekend and we made 27
which was a lot more so we made exactly
half it completely outperformed what we
thought and then the reason that we
ended up making a sequel was because it
was one of those movies that because it
hadn't been driven down anybody's throat
because no one really thought it would
be a hit audiences kind of found it on
their own so every week it over
performed what they projected and that
was only because moviegoers were
going hey you should go check this one
out it's good and and that was that was
kind of how
that kind of became our thing it was
like the the moviegoers made that
franchise
i really went as deep as i could on the
choreography for the fighting was
because i'd never done an action movie
because
people didn't think of me as an action
person and i didn't either and i really
wanted to do everything that i could to
be as believable as possible in terms of
the stunts i always defer to the stunt
team because they're great and they if
if it's safe enough for you to do
they're they'll train you up so that you
can do it those guys just take over and
and they're amazing and you can't tell
when it's me and when it's not because
because they're they're that good but i
always try to do as much as i can just
because you can hold a shot longer i
mean nowadays with face replacement you
could probably do anything but back then
you could hold a fight scene longer and
if you got all of the moves right you
can do 15 20 moves and you're like holy
[ __ ] that's that's the actor like the
actor's really doing that i did boxing
training and martial arts training and
all this stuff in the run-up to that
movie because i wanted to try to help
the movie as much as i could and and
extend some of those shots
the departed
it was in boston so i was really
uh kind of relaxed and and you know i
mean i just knew that world mark
obviously too no really knows that world
and i remember we were shooting ocean's
12 and brad came up and said
hey you want to be in a martin scorsese
movie because brad i don't know if you
know produced that and brad was going to
play
either leo or my role i can't remember
which one i guess they had spoken to
marty and marty was like no i'd like to
have matt and i thought brad was joking
i'm like
what actor do you ask that question of
who you know you're like shut up man
he's like no i'm actually serious and
then he handed me the script and it was
fantastic i just felt like that was one
of those things that fell from the sky
it's like marty was like working with
stephen you know with spielberg it's
like or coppola like wow i got to do
that i'll always be
you know grateful that i had that that
that chance and every day like it was
just you know
that scene in the elevator you know what
i mean it's just like you just feel it's
just electric when you're doing it
because um
because you're doing it
you know in front of martin scorsese
i can't wait to see you explain this to
a suffolk county jury you [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is gonna be [ __ ] fun
just
kill me
i am killing you
you know it was the the gag there is
that it's a total surprise and i know
i'm screwed and i'm begging for you know
i think i'm saying just kill me and then
the door opens and and his head gets
blown off and i i remember sitting we
were sitting there
marty had a shot of the elevator door
closing uh uh you know and opening
because leo leo was laying across the
thing closing and opening and like we
were sitting there and leo and i were
looking at it and it was like
no one's ever gonna believe like that's
leonardo dicaprio just got his head
blown off like we knew that that
surprise was gonna was gonna work
[Music]
invictus
well it's an incredible book and it was
a great script alan horn who ran warner
brothers at the time called me and told
me that he wanted me for this part and
so i immediately called clint and
i remember i got his office they said uh
oh he's not he's not here right now and
i go okay great just
he can just call me back whenever and
they go oh that's a thing we don't we
don't know when he's gonna call because
he's on vacation and nobody knows how to
reach him and when it whenever he calls
it could be a couple days but i'll give
him your message and i remember hanging
up the phone and saying to my wife wow
that's pretty cool like when you're at
the place where you're like
i'll call you in three days because i'm
with my family and i can't be bothered
i'm like wow that's that was that was
kind of neat but i just remember loving
working with him he does one take i
heard that so i worked on that south
african accent like an office job tim
monic this great dialect coach would
come
and we would from monday to friday from
from nine in the morning till five like
like it was an office job we worked for
about six months on that thing because i
knew i was only going to get one take
and on the first day i i did my first
take and i knew that i got i got it
right but i was like you know hey boss
can i have another one and he just
turned to me and goes why
you want to waste everybody's time and i
was like all right i guess we're moving
on you know so that was that was day one
with clint
heads up
looking
mad do you hear
listen to your country
seven minutes
seven minutes
defense defense defense
this is it
this is our destiny
[Applause]
he looks like an nfl linebacker he's six
foot five the first time i met him i
went to his house for dinner right when
i got to south africa and i really
admired like what that team did and what
he did and everything and
so i was excited to meet him and and i
rang the doorbell on the door open and
this guy who like took up the whole
doorway you know opened the door
big smile and and i just looked up at
him and i said i look much bigger on
film
[Music]
contagion
scott burns our writer just did a
mountain of research and and talked to
all the experts they explained exactly
what would happen and the movie's really
accurate it was eerie you know for all
of us to look at it once the world
started to kind of imitate the movie you
know luckily covid wasn't as deadly as
the virus in uh in our movie you know
and for anybody who said we couldn't
have predicted this and how could we
have known it's like well a movie came
out about it 10 years before that i kind
of told you everything not because we
and if people in hollywood have some
kind of any kind of secret answers or we
guessed but because we actually just
took the time to talk to
experts and let them lead our story been
working here
just get this here
jory don't touch anything
help me
[Music]
well ian lipkin who was our technical
advisor who's who you know he does for a
living he identifies viruses and he
explained that he identifies a new one
every week they're able to kind of
figure out what it is like this is kind
of bird that you know and they can
figure it out and stop it but there are
these kind of outbreaks that happen all
over the world all the time and you talk
to that guy and like you definitely
you know
you definitely feel like this could
happen
[Music]
the martian
that was the first thing i said to
ridley scott i was like i don't know if
i can do this and he was like why and i
said well because i literally just
played you know the move the
interstellar hadn't come out and i go
it's not a big part but i am a guy alone
on a planet you know and i don't know if
i should follow it up with the guy who's
alone on a planet
nobody
yeah i'm so glad he said that to me
because i took the leap and i'm really
glad i did obviously
i'm entering this log for the record
uh in case i don't make it
uh it is
oh 6 53
on seoul 19 and
i'm alive
obviously but
i'm guessing that's going to come as a
surprise to my crewmates and to nasa
and to the entire world really so
surprised
there was a scripted moment when the
character was supposed to break down and
when we got to it we felt forced and
ridley and i kind of looked at each
other and we're like
this doesn't feel right does it and we
both kind of felt that same you know we
were in the same movie together and we
think yeah no and we were getting
towards the end of the schedule
and i thought we were gonna kind of find
a new little scene to do
where i'm about to like get reunited
with my
team we'd shot stuff with the other
actors months earlier but they'd all
gone home and ridley and i had made all
those scenes but just together where it
was just me on camera and so suddenly i
heard
in my helmet as the you know as the
gimbal starts to shutter as if this
thing is going to take off and the light
effects start to happen and like and you
really feel like you know you're about
to kind of take off and suddenly i heard
the voices of all of these actors who
were my buddies you know and and it's
and it dawned on me
you know thinking through the kind of
the filter of this character like he
hadn't heard a voice
in a year and that these people had made
this sacrifice to come back
for him
about two minutes what day how are you
doing down there i'm good
i'm anxious to get up to you
[Music]
thanks for coming back for me well we're
on it remember we'll be pulling some
serious g so it's okay to pass out
you're in martinez's hands now well
tell that about no barrel rules
copy that mav
capcom
go remote command go
recovery
go
secondary recovery
go
pilot
go
they came all the way back
you know they slingshot around earth and
come back you know what i mean it's like
it was so humbling it just totally
happened and it wasn't planned that's
just great directing that's ridley just
just kind of put a move on me i didn't
see it coming you know that one of those
things it's over in five minutes that's
just down to great directing
[Music]
true grit
well that was just the chance to work
with the cone brothers really and on the
technical side it was like trying to
figure out the tongue thing when he gets
his tongue
yeah injured and that we figured out i
was sitting in a makeup trailer one day
on another movie and picked up a hair
tie and just put it around my twist
started twisting it around my tongue and
just tried to speak normally and that
was how we kind of came up with that
little gag but those guys are
unbelievably prepared like they
storyboard everything and now they're at
the stage where despite having
everything meticulously storyboarded
they don't really adhere to the
storyboards anymore because they're so
experienced they can kind of
you know if a better idea comes to them
on the spot they just kind of drive in
that direction and they just it was
really they're really efficient and just
amazing
in conference you cannot side our
agreement you're the one who shot me mr
the beef has a point marshall it is an
unfair leg up in any competition to
shoot your opposite number goddamn it i
do not accept it as a given that i did
shoot le beave there are plenty of guns
going off i heard the rifle and i felt
the ball you missed your shot cockburn
here's my shot you were more handicapped
without the eye than i without the arm
that was great i mean and also doing a
western with them and with jeff
you know and haley was like 13 and she
was so sweet that was another situation
where jeff and i kind of as parents were
like very
everyone was i mean to be fair i mean
you know everyone there was wanted to
make sure that she had a good time and i
think she really did and she's amazing
in the movie too she was another one of
those it's like obscenely gifted you
know child actors
ford versus ferrari
it was so much fun working with him i
had a blast he's i mean he's
unbelievably professional he comes at it
out of a place of joy and i'm the same
way we both love what we do i think he's
aware of his reputation as being so you
know
serious the very first day
the director jim mangold who's great we
got our first shot off and jim comes
running in he's a big personality and he
just launches into okay well you do that
on that line look at him and he starts
giving us these notes but but it's big
like it's you know it's almost like a
performance huh
how long has that been
oh it's got to be three or four years at
least
let me show it yeah scca divisional
championship
you broke my finger
was that
such a
nippy
nippy bloody thing
did you want to hear all that thing i
call that the llama bite he's just this
bigger than life guy he goes all right
let's go take two and he goes running
back to behind the camera and christian
just turned to me and goes
who was that guy and i think it was his
way of going like
this is going to be fun we don't have to
out serious one another because if you
come at it from a place of joy and
relaxation and your work's always going
to be better
you ready the name on the middle of that
steering wheel should tell you that i
was born ready shelby hit it attaboy
the cars we drove would be the shell of
a car with like a miata engine
so i think the real cars are all in
museums we did work one day with the
shell of a car and just the shell of an
original cobra it just had police tape
around it it was worth over a million
dollars it was just the most beautiful
thing but yeah no those real cars are
something
still water
that was one of the things i loved it
was like because that's a very very
specific thing a rough neck from
oklahoma that can even do that job most
people can't do it i couldn't do it for
sure and so to play someone like that
transplanted to marseille which is a
really specific city in france it's not
paris it's marseille and i just thought
that it was you know beautifully written
and the dynamics between
you know me and my daughter played by
abby breslin and then this other kind of
new family that he finds a woman he
falls in love with and her daughter her
eight-year-old daughter he suddenly has
the relationship with her that he
couldn't have with his own kid and all
of the pain and the regret and the shame
that he carries and we talk about it as
kind of like a dramatic thriller it's
got kind of the bones of the you know
the guy goes to exonerate his daughter
and it and it looks like it might be
that movie and it's not it's something
very different the father of the girl he
the american student
yes ma'am
allison came here for college and that's
where she met this girl lina
one night she found lena dead and called
the police
all they cared about was alison sleeping
with some arab girl she'd never acted
before and she's just one of those kids
who's a natural and you never know what
you're gonna get with a kid and after
the first day tom and i sat down and
just said okay well we gotta make sure
this doesn't get messed up we have to
keep this as as fun and playful and
joyful for her french laws helped us
there a bit because they're really
strict about how many hours a kid can
work she never got exhausted she never
got burned out by the process which
which can happen to adults you know and
so when she was on set everybody was
kind of
uh all hands on deck ready to go she was
you know somehow naturally just did
things differently every take like she
just couldn't do it the same way twice
which is you know technique that takes
decades for most people to learn thanks
a lot for watching if you made it this
far if i missed anything
then just write in the chats or whatever
however you kids do it and
we'll talk about it next time